Now let us consider analogical mapping. The problem here is called
the correspondent's problem. There are a number of obvious relationships in this
target problem. There are a number of obvious relationships in this source case.
What in the target problem corresponds to what in the source case?
If we can address the correspondence problem. If we can say, for
example, that the laser beam corresponds to the rebel army,
then we can start aligning the target problem and
the source case so it makes the deep similarities between relationships salient.
Note there are several parts of a target problem and several in the source case.
In principle, any of these objects of the target problem could correspond to any
of the objects in the source case. In which case we would have an m
to n mapping, and that becomes computationally inefficient. If you and I,
often do not have much of a problem deciding, if the laser beam must correspond
to the devil army. How do we do it? And how can we help AI agents make
similar kind of correspondences? Our answer is, we'll make use of relationships.
In fact, we'll make use of higher order relationships, whenever possible.
We'll give precedence to higher order relationships, over other relationships.
As a unary relationship, we might say that a patient is a person here, and
king is a person there. The binary relationship we might say, that physician has
a resource, the laser beam. And that the rebel army has a resource, the army
itself. It's a higher ordered relationship, a tertiary relationship between say,
that between the goal and the resource is an obstacle. They held a tissue in
this case. Similarly between the goal and the resource is an obstacle,
the minds in this case. We focus on the higher ordered relationship there,
that's where the deepest similarity between the two situations lies. This is
how we know to mark between the king and the tumor and not between the king and
the patient. Although the king and the patient are superficially similar,
a deeper similarity lies in viewing the king and
the tumor in terms of goals which need to be cured or
captured using a resource when there is an obstacle in between them.